this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up friends Michael here to ask
what could you accomplish if you were
productive 24 7. well the latest episode
of Rick and Morty poses this question
with disturbing implications but is
there anything deeper going on when
Morty forces his night self to Crunch
his way to an eight pack let's find out
in this wisecrack quick take on Rick and
Morty season 6 episode 4 are we already
night people but before we get into it I
want to tell you about this video
sponsor surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn keeps
your data secure everywhere you go on
the Internet thanks to their secure
protocols and uncrackable encryption
something I love about using surf shark
is the way it keeps my location
completely private which is a major
advantage when buying things like plane
tickets because if a website doesn't
know where I am they can't gouge the
prices based on what they think I can
afford which is not a lot all I have to
do is connect my secure surfsharkvpn to
other vpns around the world until I
track down the best price and speaking
of the world these connections also make
it easy to watch all the content that
hasn't been released in your country yet
all your favorite devices are included
in a single subscription including your
laptop Android Amazon Fire stick
PlayStation and more plus you can still
use your favorite apps like Chrome and
Firefox so get started by clicking the
link in the description and using the
promo code wisecraft when you do you can
get search shark VPN for 83 off plus
three extra months for free so go to
surfshark.deals slash wisecrack or hit
the link in the description protect
yourself online and download
surfsharkvpn today now back to the show
we kick off with Beth having her couch
rest interrupted by this what are you
doing we quickly learned that he's
harnessed the power of His night self
with the help of some space technology
to be productive while everyone else
sleeps before I go to bed I type a list
of [ __ ] I want to get done then the
Sumney ambulator programs my unconscious
body or night person to do it while I
sleep the family soon follows suit only
Jerry sweet dumb Jerry this seems to be
missing out on the self-improvement
trend instead choosing to treat his
night self as a new pen pal I also like
Tori Amos hope you like our new pajamas
what is the sun Jerry this isn't how
you're supposed to use a night person
but the rest of the family is pursuing
something that's all too common nowadays
self-optimization as journalist
Alexandra Schwartz points out the idea
of self-help has evolved significantly
since the mid-auts we've shifted from
the positive ideation encouraged by then
bestseller the secret to a Blazer focus
on improving the self in quantifiable
ways she writes it's no longer enough to
imagine our way to a better state of
body or mind we must now chart our
progress count our steps log our sleep
rhythms tweak our diets record our
negative thoughts then analyze the data
recalibrate and repeat this pressure has
most recently manifested in the
widespread education of self-optimizing
Technology we talk about
self-optimization in our recent video on
productivity so check that one out if
you haven't yet as we watched the family
engaging in self-improvement in the wee
hours of the morning we were reminded of
the concept of Auto exploitation as
discussed by philosopher Jung Chul Han
he explains that Society used to be
based around external discipline
Foucault's world of hospitals mad houses
prisons barracks and factories but today
he writes 21st century Society is no
longer a disciplinary Society but rather
an achievement Society also its
inhabitants are no longer obedience
subjects but achievement subjects they
are entrepreneurs of themselves that is
to say the world used to be dictated by
what we should or should not do but now
it's motivated positively by what we can
do Han refers to this as the positivity
of can so rather than being pushed to
improve by your boss or teachers
government you're pushed by yourself put
differently the boss lives inside your
head now paradoxically he argues this
creates a real loss of personal autonomy
under Auto exploitation we become
prisoners of our own desire to succeed
we see the Smiths engaged in literal
Auto exploitation self-discipline
becomes the name of the game and the
knightsmiths are forced to endure the
labor of their day selves desire for
improvement obviously this doesn't lead
anywhere good but what's the effect of
this phenomenon in real life according
to Han it's bad he writes that in the
achievement Society we're put in a
condition of compulsive Freedom that is
to the free constraint of maximizing
achievement excess work and performance
escalate into Auto exploitation as a
result he writes one exploits oneself it
means that exploitation is possible even
without domination if you used to be
able to blame your boss for how hard you
were forced to work you can now pretty
much blame yourself and an increasingly
precarious economy that necessitates
such hard work in the first place the
result of this self-monitoring is as Han
explains that the achievement subject
finds itself fighting with itself we see
this manifest in the episode as the
tensions between the day and night
people escalate night summer imprisons
the Day family forcing them to partake
in the same self-optimizing behavior
they voiced it on their night selves
also if anyone's watching this and
you're thinking about the nightman
Dayman thing from Always Sunny I am too
maybe we'll put a Quick Clip right here
foreign
classic television the characters are
torn between their two selves each of
whom wants to use the other to optimize
and improve for their own benefit
self-optimization has clearly turned
them into their own worst enemies but
the one exception is Jerry who from the
get-go treated his night self very
differently rather than programming him
to do thankless acts of
self-optimization Jerry turned his
alternate self into a new pen pal they
shared kind words explored uh the big
questions and generally exchanged
thoughts about their different
experiences wait until night Jerry reads
about this Jerry addressed his night
self with compassion and curiosity
viewing him as a human being rather than
as a vehicle for achieving
self-improvement Knight Jerry said night
summer would appreciate it if everybody
could rinse off their plates after
eating as a result Jerry is the only
night person who extends an olive branch
to the family anything
update Jerry's family because he's the
only one not at war with himself he
comes closest to facilitating peace but
of course this is Rick and Morty so Rick
stubbornness ruins all of that we can
end all of this right now if you agree
to rinse your dishes what do you say
Rick by the end even the night selves
have realized that keeping up with all
the optimization and achievement has
left them broke and miserable in this
way Jerry embodies a different way of
thinking about our modern identities as
self-improving achievement subjects
rather than prioritizing accomplishment
Jerry prioritizes his and his night
selves well-being this is Meaningful as
Han writes we owe the cultural
achievements of humanity which include
philosophy to deep contemplative
attention culture presumes an
environment in which deep attention is
possible in treating his night self as a
pen pal Jerry's doing what all our
therapists beg us to do he's checking in
with himself and paying a 10 attention
to his emotional experiences according
to Han unchecked self-improvement leads
to burnout depression and an overall
loss of personal freedom in short our
obsession with self-optimization risks
turning us into our very own night
people except for us there isn't even
the Blissful ignorance of not knowing
our night people as we're the same ones
who have to stay up late to make sure
we're optimizing our lives and achieving
more than those around us oh what a
world we live in friends this is why
it's encouraging to see Jerry's
mentality increasingly being reflected
in our broader culture recently a
phenomena like quiet quitting see a
growing number of people pushing back
against the expectations of our hyper
productive Society expectations that are
making us push ourselves harder than
ever before and still feel like we're
not accomplishing nearly enough although
of course quiet quitting basically just
boils down to just doing your job but in
a normal way so it's kind of like let's
go back to the old school exploitation
of hiding from our boss's DMS instead of
the auto exploitation of checking our
email at 2 am on a Saturday and
according to journalist will store this
re-examination of productivity is
encouraging he writes what it actually
leads us towards is a better way of
finding happiness once you realize that
it's all just an act of coercion that
it's your culture trying to turn you
into someone you can't really be you can
begin to free yourself from your demands
which as the Smith family eventually
learns might mean accepting that you'll
never be fluent in Spanish or a
professional trumpet player or a little
ABS Master pow pow
even if it means you'll never get Nancy
Pelosi on your podcast wanna drop her on
her ABS ah yeah but what do you guys
think are the Smiths and their nighttime
selves just the latest victims of
burnout culture are we treating
ourselves as badly as they treat their
Knight family let us know in the
comments huge thanks to our patrons for
all your support and if you want to
learn more about our patreon perks which
include access to our Discord server
extra content early video releases with
no ads then check out patreon.com
wisecrack or just check out the link in
the description please be sure to like
this video And subscribe to the channel
to make all of our Auto exploitation
worth it as always thank you so much for
watching later
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]